日本経済を再生する方法ビッグモーター
から車を買わないことソポの保険に入ら
ないこと定期的に東京を壊滅しにくる
ゴジラをそろそろ買いならすこと影分身税
を導入することまあこの葉は潰れちゃう
けど何があっても宮本さんを守ること絶対
に宮崎監督を引退させないこと今まで
トヨタにあげていた補助金を全部フロム
ソフトウェアに投げ込むことそして言う
までもないがブラッドボーン2を作っ
いただくことお願いです大工さが足りない
地域に電磁を送り込むことたまには自民党
以外の党に表を投じること同線なら
ポケモンを線引き発表することお土産を
購入するたびに投資ファンドに1000円
を入れること1年以内に国民全員が億万
長者になる日進様に今度は線図を開発して
いただくこと絶対買えますこっそりと全て
の緑茶商品のカフェイン料を倍にすること
中学生にYouTubeはちゃんとした
仕事じゃないというのをやめること傷つい
ちゃうよ俺誰にも負けない根性と天才的な
技術で圧倒的なパワーを持っている海外の
電気自動車に打ち勝つ藤原巧とその86と
いうイニシャルDの続編を作ることいや
面白いと思わない操作にお金をかけなくて
もいいように迷惑系YouTuberを
捕まえやすくする法律を作ることうんいや
俺迷惑系じゃないよ全国の100均を
200金にすることこの国を支えているの
は政治家じゃなくてダイソとセリアの商品
開発部だそろそろ彼らにもっと感謝すべき
だトンネル掘は全部5条悟るにお願いする
こと紫自分と他人の間の信頼をお祝いする
ための小さな絵としてイ文化を欧米に紹介
してその効率を下げること
ONE
大学に上がっても勉強を続けること一刻も
早くUberを導入すること天商品にAI
技術を加えること俺のためじゃないよ
そして国の出産率がさらに下がってしまっ
たらMacのアニメCMをもっと増やす
ことそろそろマッパに休憩を与えること
休憩せずにいい仕事ができる人間なんて誰
もいないからねあれもしかしてMacの
あのアニメのCMもマッパが作ってる
イライラしない銀行アプリを開発すること
強分離をちゃんとすることガンダムを
もっと作ること今大阪関西万博に使って
いる税金を全部セガに当ててドリーム
キャスト2を作っていただく
ことうわ今言っただけで鳥肌立った
わ
DET